ça y est les jeux de tokyo sont
terminées alors bravo à tous ceux qui
ont participé tous ceux qui nous ont
fait rêver tous ceux qui ont apporté
évidemment y compris pour le camp
français des nombreuses médailles et
commence à partir d'aujourd'hui
l'olympia de paris
2024 et vous savez que le conseil
départemental de la vienne il est engagé
depuis le début on a été un soutien à la
candidature de paris 2024 et puis on a
participé on est toujours engagé aux
côtés de de terre de jeu et puis harry
des équipements exceptionnels comme
l'aréna au futuroscope qui est d'ores et
déjà labellisés pour pouvoir accueillir
irrigation ou des épreuves préparatoires
puis sio au vélodrome de loudun
vélodrome qui a été construit en 1890
parce que voilà le sport dans la vienne
c'est quelque chose aussi discret car on
va profiter peut-être 2 de cet olympia
de ces deux trois ans qu'on a devant
nous pour vous faire comme ça re
découvrir l'histoire d'un certain nombre
de lieux stades piscines ici un
vélodrome quasi unique il en existe un
autre à buxerolles des lieux qui ont
fait l'histoire du sport dans la vienne
a très vite
[Musique]
on